it's a shot that can save lives the
vaccination guards against the human
papilloma virus the primary cause of
cervical cancer in 2011 Rwanda launched
a nationwide program to vaccinate
adolescent girls against HPV therefore
vaccination rate from over 90% with is
much higher than even most of the
developed countries and this shows the
great engagement and the plan the
Rwandan government has to address this
rule and ah's economy has expanded
quickly over the last 20 years the
current growth rate exceeds 7 percent
the healthcare system has improved
dramatically too
residents can go to health centers or to
district hospitals if they need further
treatment funding is provided through a
Health Insurance Scheme health insurance
is very important because it gives us
access to medical care it's difficult
without insurance because medical bills
are too expensive to pay on your own
weevils are pretty teacher it would have
to be someone one of the healthcare
systems showcased district hospitals is
in Butare oh it's the only one with an
oncology department women with cervical
cancer can be operated on here but even
here in boot ro the healthcare advances
have their limits patients requiring
chemotherapy and/or radiotherapy have to
travel to neighboring Uganda the
downside of Wenders economic boom more
and more people are developing illnesses
more typical of affluent countries non
communicable diseases such as cancer
hypertension and diabetes these
illnesses were in the spotlight of the
World Economic Forum on Africa in the
Rwandan capital Kigali in mid-may they
are putting an increasing burden on
economies throughout the continent
the problem is 80% of the burden of
cancer is in emerging economies and 5%
of the health care spending dedicated to
cancer is in emerging economies so you
see you see you see precisely the
dilemma cooperation with international
drugs companies could be part of the
solution for example in Kenya's Swiss
pharmaceutical company Novartis offers
discounted drugs to treat chronic
diseases the project could be rolled out
in Rwanda
the money would need to come from the
procurement agencies in the public
sector and that from the countries or
from the procuring non-governmental
organisations or at one point in time
hopefully also from donors Rwanda
vaccination program against the human
papillomavirus is an example of
successful international cooperation the
scheme is organized by the state which
also pays for the vaccine costs Merck
has lowered its price to five dollars
per dose one twentieth of the normal
rate the vaccine Alliance Garvey
negotiated the deal it's a team work we
had a great support from the Minister of
Education that really during the the day
of vaccination of a girl at school do a
special Health Day and also to tell us
who are the children not at school that
day so that we can reach them to the
community health workers the dream of
protecting an entire generation of women
from cervical cancer is becoming reality
in Rwanda and the program could be a
trailblazer for the rest of Africa